[Musique]
en mai dernier dix danseurs réunionnais
porteurs de handicap ont remporté trois
médailles lors de leur première
participation concours national
andy danse à bourges le conseil
départemental qui a contribué à ce
voyage a souhaité les recevoir à la
villa du département pour les féliciter
a été un voyage tellement enrichissant
tellement magnifique que l'île de la
réunion a remporté les deux premiers
prix et un deux et un troisième deuxième
prix pour une première fois que ces
jeunes quitter la réunion quitter leur
famille et qui se retrouvaient là bas à
être plébiscité par tous tous les clubs
de france
les danseurs ont présenté au total trois
chorégraphies de danse indienne qui ont
chacune remporté un prix l'offrande de
fleurs a reçu
donc le prix de la chorégraphie la plus
poétique
ensuite pour la danse des saris donc
danses de groupe qui a été aussi
présenté par la cph avec moi sur scène
ils ont
également reçu un prix et mais cette
fois ci le premier prix pour la
chorégraphie arc-en-ciel de bonheur et
pour la 3ème chorégraphie qui a été
présenté par la compagnie danse et
massala donc j'étais en duo avec marie
claire d'amour pour coup de foudre à
bollywood
nous avons reçu donc le prix de la
chorégraphie la plus expressive donc
médaille d'or une expérience riche en
émotion pour ces personnes qui n'avaient
encore jamais quitté leur île mais
surtout une grande fierté d'avoir gagné
on a dansé on parlait du rhône
bien et
des médailles d'argent c'était une belle
aventure qu'on a vécu en france par
notre acharnement notre volonté à tous
d'avoir bien travaillé à la réunion sur
deux chorégraphies bas on était assez
confiants mais bon quand on arrivé là
bas y avait quand même 600 danseurs et
c'était un gros con copponi ben c'était
précieux pour gagner mais on a gardé
confiance en nous et on a réussi ce que
je retiens c'est que ben tout est
possible et tout est adaptable et que
ben
ces tops de danser
de jouer la carte de mettre lyon et de
danser devant
600 personnes et plus et d'être belles
dans l'est elle à l'espace d'un instant
d'être une star en fait ou alors
[Musique]